you are nothing compared to what you
could be so believe it no but you're not
taking the action this is not the reason
to stay in a job that you're not
learning enough I understand I
understand you're gonna be unstoppable
you're already unstoppable it's just
like you figure it out now at 17 or do
you wait till 27 to get some help with
my with my schedule my time manager yeah
and all of that aspect of my life yeah
which is something that I feel I have in
pupula okay but I need to if I wanna go
to like the next level like sharpen on
yeah 100% and you don't figure it out
now like yeah it only gets more
complicated exact wife kids job like
it's gonna get our easy yeah and it's
being a weakness for me for so long
okay we'll get different issues okay you
know I have like a DVD I know which is
an excuse yeah like ha maybe has
something to do about yeah anyways so so
there's there's different things that
are having my life right now that I
talked to one and I would like to be
able to feed all of them in my schedule
or or I realized if I had to cut
something off yeah like as I told you
yeah my life right now is divided into
school were just taking a lot of my time
work which is taking more and more of my
time which is something that I feel I
have to you want to do you don't wanna
do I wanna do because it's I learned the
opportunity that it's so big of an
opportunity okay I don't feel I'm
learning as much as I thought I would
okay and but I think the opportunity in
the future it's it's big okay I mean I'm
really confused
no no I got here yes okay and I was a
correct one and at all there's the
project that I wanna build for the
Entrepreneurship kind of community club
called it as you know at school at
school but I want it to be more like I
wanted to be what I would love yeah it's
build something like what we have what
we have here yeah
back in back in Montreux okay I would
honestly love to build like belief
nation
yeah like Montreux believe nation
something like that yeah when are you
gonna school two years and what is that
in use
I'm studying it's a new program called
entrepreneurship and business management
okay so you want to be an entrepreneur
ideally came out of it I would like to
but I would love to and and I think I
don't know if your honors if you know a
little bit how the Quebec system works
which is a little bit different from
here because you got to see Jeb over
there which is after you go out of high
school
right I think I talked to you about it
you before going to university or you're
obligated to do something called see Jeb
which could be like college okay it
could be like college in here okay but
and you have two types of programs you
have pre university and technical
programs so my program is a technical
program meaning that it's three-year
long okay okay but then you serve
something after not Ness I don't have to
okay I don't think the university is
gonna be for me okay is that are you
learning from the job or is it just
money not it's not money I'm paid
minimum wage okay are you learning from
the job I think I am learning but I'm
not learning what I thought I was gonna
learn but I still think I'm like look I
got it into the job I was looking for an
internship in marketing okay so what I
was thinking I would get I have a mentor
back in Montreux it has a company he
sells furniture online and he knows all
about digital marketing I actual
practical like digital marketing so I
was gonna get the internship with him
and I went to a networking event just a
couple days before and I found his
opportunity which is like such a big big
company that I taught myself like it's a
big opinion I did take it but what am i
what I'm actually doing is more things
like yeah dealing with the main menu
yeah with letting go back to the other
guy yeah so Billy will he pay you the
same or more I didn't even brought the
subject to him because I got the other
internship and after that got the
internship I got the job and so right
now I'm like doing the job so so I'm
there I'm good I just I want to keep
with it why because I know learning
anything and you're making minimum wage
I if that guy said hey Sebastian I have
a I have a spot for you
we're gonna be making the same or a
little bit more and I
I'm gonna teach you I have I feel the
trust that because as I told you it's
not a big company compared to the
industry but it's kind of a big company
and I feel the trust that has be has
been putting on me like I feel that what
we were saying it's not that they don't
believe in me is it it's your whole mess
of what were you what were you doing
your thought leadership on yeah like the
people who want for you anymore you
don't owe them anything I don't owe them
anything so you don't own this company
anything but I feel I wanna like I feel
like but you're not everything that I've
done in life I don't like you don't want
of the questions like what do you feel
the most proud of and the only thing I
could think about was having switched my
bad relationships to like becoming this
despite the worsening everything but I
don't feel like I've had an
accomplishment because everything that
I'm I have started something I have
always stopped and this is something
that I started and I to myself it has
not even but it's not it's not it's not
even that says that's not the reason
it's saying something because you're
moving forward it's not like I'm gonna
quit this job because I couldn't make it
and I'm gonna go and be yeah that's why
I don't feel because I feel it's only
how you feel it's not how it is yeah so
if the guy would take you like listen
you have a responsibility okay great you
don't have to leave this company right
now you can give them a couple weeks
notice but you're not learning what you
want to learn and you're getting paid
minimum wage okay but you can learn
something anywhere and you can be a
janitor and learn something like go work
for somebody who you're gonna learn a
lot from the reason to get a job is to
learn or to make money to like if you
said hey you know what I'm making enough
that I can support myself through school
I'm making decent wages okay I'm still
on a huge fan because I think you can
make money and do something you love but
I get the reason but you're making
minimum wage it's not super impressive
right so it should be easier to leave it
this guy will give you plus like ideally
more than what you're making but even if
it just gives you what you're making but
he's gonna mentor you
and help teach you that's what that's
what you want being with that guy like
how much have you learned in the past
couple days the growth the energy but
the strategies the ideas that breaking
through if you're around that every day
who are you gonna be in two years you
know I get it I get it I completely get
it and I know I won't be there for like
forever but well why wait the reason why
wait is because I've been trusted I have
taken the challenge personally like this
is a challenge for me because as we were
talking it's a bit a big company it's
something that doing marketing on social
media for b2b companies and in that
industry specifically doing it you're
not learning to I know that if I take on
the challenge on a and I give my all and
if I started get results with him with
him what I want to implement with them
how works I will be learning of course
but it's opportunity cost you could be
learning way more somewhere else you're
not quitting you're moving to something
better and not worse it's like you quit
on something it's like you're on your
you're on your workout routine and maybe
you quit on that and then you get fat so
you really think oh yeah you shouldn't
be like I think you should message the
guy right now even if I'm telling you
that it's not that I don't know anything
because that's what I'm trying to but of
course you you want to learn your
response but you'll learn and you could
learn being a cleaner here like my
cleaner here likes hanging out here just
to hear the conversations I get it but
you can learn way more so you're gonna
wait a year learning 10% of what you
should be learning because it feel like
you owe it to yourself to not quit on
something that's not the right reason
you're gonna you're not quitting you're
moving forward you would you follow
baseball or something if you thought
baseball know what's your sport I
watched soccer soccer what's your team
your main like okay yeah Barcelona okay
so whatever doesn't matter so like
here's the thing actually one of our
players can even play just got like
drafted to go play and for you vague or
something
so Barcelona great you're a talented you
know sixteen year old up-and-coming
superstar right right are you 17 now
are you really 17 Jesus Christ this
guy's 17 I just made 16 up I thought you
were like 22 or something holy cow dude
dude you're like you're awesome 417 man
serious holy Christ that's crazy
yeah man do me at 17 unbelievable you're
like set for life I'm serious that's
crazy
holy cow you're hanging with all these
people who are yeah it's ridiculous but
you're bringing light and energy to
everybody here
anyway I'm I got a bike digest that for
a second but that's crazy but where's
the thing okay so you're actually 17
great you're this is great you're a 17
year old soccer or football phenom right
you're playing and you're you're playing
and like I don't know what's a what's a
where you Lebanon you claim like the
Lebanese league right like trash I'm
gonna hate you for that
okay you're playing in Lebanese like
Deeley like the worst of all time but
you mean II like you guys signed to play
there and and barsa comes and says hey
come play with us and you're saying no I
want to quit on every other team so I'm
gonna stay with my Lebanese team just
because that's it's not the reason go
play for Barcelona I maybe this guy is
not Barcelona but maybe he's like Serie
B Italy like it's step up from Lebanon
you're gonna learn more you're gonna get
when you're on when you play on
Barcelona you become a better player
than when you stay in Lebanon did I say
that right when I talked young I tell
you I just feel like when I quit this
job
you know wouldn't know okay when I led
this job can I see that when I let it
okay when you landed this job and I let
no I mean when I
let when you left we're not when when
I'm gonna let when you're gonna leave
when I'm gonna leave yes job yeah I want
to do it and start doing my thing like
why go work for this guy a go work for a
better you need to be learning at the
job that you want to become like you
need to have a lot of learning at the
business that you're in and you need to
be or you'd be getting paid some decent
money for it the thing is I I think
we're I'm working right now I can learn
a lot no I don't have someone that's
gonna be teaching so then you're not
gonna learn a lot how much you learn in
a company is a direct relationship to
how good your boss is a guiding you if
your boss sucks you're not gonna learn
you know I've built like this kind of
close relationship with the steel and
the times that I've traveled to where
the test quarters are the conversations
that we're just telling yourself you're
just telling yourself you're just afraid
that you're quitting on it and you want
to have accomplishment and say like I
did this here everything you're saying
is I'm not learning anything I could
learn something but you can learn
something anywhere and you're making
minimum wage you could be learning a lot
more whether it's this guy or somewhere
else you could be learning a lot more
how much you've learned here in the past
two days is more than you've learned in
the past like 16 months of being at your
company how long have you been there
three months when it comes
okay so far so five months you've
learned more in two days here than there
in five months I don't even know that
guy but I'm betting on it oh great but
that but that's what you need to be
around this is more valuable what you
learned what you learned into two days
is more valuable than what you're
learning but look I'm looking at I'm
forcing myself to adapt to a difficult
culture organizational culture but
that's not what you need to do right now
you need to learn the skills go go jump
off mountains and you can learn how to
adapt to the culture like there's a lot
of things you can do to scare yourself
there's a lot of difficult things you
can do this guy yourself
this is not the reason to staying in a
job that you're not learning enough you
should learn more you should be with the
company that sees potential in you that
wants to help you up but it's not enough
it's not up I get it they this is the
problem these people pinch of course of
course otherwise you wouldn't be there
at all but good is the enemy of great if
you have a good girlfriend you don't
want to let her go because she's good
but if she sucks if she's if you come
home every day and your girlfriend's
like smack you in the face like you want
to get out of that if it's bad you want
to leave but this is just good it's just
barely good enough that you don't want
to leave I want you to have great
everybody's blown away you're 17 they're
like our heads are freaking out there
they're like they might jump off their
alien if they find a head like caution
them like sit down before I tell you
this like we're all blown away by your
talent it's insane I don't know what
that's the problem that's why you stay
and why do people not go get better
relationships because this this is what
they believe they deserve and I get it
because of where you come from because
of the upbringing in the friends in
situation and where you are now compared
to where you were is a lifetime of
difference and your friends to where you
were looking at you now it's like oh my
god like I would love to be where you're
at but it's still your message you are
nothing compared to what you could be so
believe it I do know but you're not
taking the action if you believe that
you are nothing compared to what you
could be you would not be in this job
because even though you're 17 you got
you got tons of time it's still treating
like this time has to matter and this is
not the time to force yourself to work
in AD if you want to work in a difficult
culture go go you'd do anything
go be a alligator trainer okay that's
difficult alligators they chained
alligators like you'll have difficulties
all along the way at least have it be a
difficulty that like it's gonna you're
gonna learn and grow from should I let
some time in the company just to at
least wrap things up because I've made
confident invest in me like you didn't
make them do anything - no but they put
me projects that I've done I've gone
through awesome artists and I started
the project okay right now it's me we're
heading this project up but don't be
it's six months you shouldn't be there
yeah normally it's a two-week notice and
they're used to people dropping up to
two weeks and so you can say three weeks
you can stay forward so you can even
help them on the side afterwards if you
really want to be a good dude it's kind
of doubling right now because I'm only
supposed to be working two days a week
so my weekend so you're already whining
that your hours not getting I don't know
I really owe them because my school is
full time during the week my word your
prison only are you working more than
you're getting paid yeah but I'm
bringing the value I'm bringing more
value that I'm receiving that's the
equation did you just hear what you said
you're bringing more value than your
receiving that's the equation why are
you there
but isn't it what it's supposed to be
you need to bring unity than you receive
yes but you're not getting on you
progress in life I feel that I can
progress but you could progress faster
somewhere else I could you don't owe
them anything anymore you've given more
value than you've received you say I owe
them I got to finish my stuff you
brought them more value than you've
received yeah but so you got to go
somewhere else but at least the projects
that I have I study I started reading
their social media from zero from Sergey
had nothing and I started and I'm the
only one doing right now and also be
like you know what your social media I'm
just leaving you're gonna say fu you're
not gonna say f you know I'll believe in
them but but listen I mean I want to
have the me not they don't even
appreciate they do that's the thing that
I'm trying to know you're you dude I've
talked to you they're fighting you you
can't find we can't get the CEO they're
not fighting their juice old mentality
but I got ink and I'm sure that if I
stay there was the wrong reason it's the
wrong reason
don't be an ass don't just say I'm out
of here don't don't throw water balloons
at them like don't be an ass about it
like they need a I don't care it doesn't
matters to be denied there that was my
previous job of course yeah I did I know
it's way better but you're nothing
/ - what you could be so you have to
start believing that you don't have to
treat them like their asses have respect
give them a transition plan normally
it's two weeks
lots of people quit on two weeks and in
the two weeks people mail it in those
last two weeks they're slacking they're
not doing anything they're forgetting to
do work like that last two weeks is
never productive you make it the most
productive two weeks like if Sebastian's
working on something it's kick-ass and
I'm working on these two weeks and I'll
give you three weeks to help do
everything you need if you need
something that extra after like email me
because I want to see you win awesome
but you got at some point stand up for
yourself and believe in you and go chase
the opportunity that's what I wanted
that's why I wanted to talk about the
schedule because I really want to find a
way that I can address all those issues
I don't believe that I cannot do my my
social I believe that I can do my social
media like but like this is the schedule
this is how you adjust your schedule you
look at what you're working on and is it
gonna help you accomplish what you want
and you would everything we just did
with your job you apply to everything so
school is helping me get to where I want
to go maybe but do I want to quit no
like see quitting on school to go do
something else I can't understand you
want to keep you want to finish the
school and say hey but you don't want to
finish it I would feel more inclined
towards quitting school right now than
quitting that job it's it's that kind of
thing because that way you shouldn't
because there's another job that is
better for you that you're gonna make
more money at that you can get a little
more learning that that you're trading
up if you quit on school to something
else you have to be trading up alright
now I know that I'm not gonna be there
forever and I know that I'm gonna find
something better but just it okay so
when really it's no really so what is it
to write on your ID when is it when is
it too early to believe that you are
capable of more I am capable of more
better no no it's not even capable - of
handling the things that I have right
now you're capable but not because I
haven't read them results enough you're
not quitting because you're not capable
you brought them more value than you're
getting paid for
yeah but the value that I'm bringing has
not brought the results yet that's the
problem I'm still working that's not
that's not the really started I just
started you know that's not the reason
it'll never be you'll never get there
because it's always gonna be a new
project and you're always gonna keep
building momentum it's it's net you're
never gonna get this budget right now is
building their social media presence
dude that's what I'm done every times is
okay please I want to build the strategy
I want to build their give this talk
sure given the structure two weeks
build the structure they're gonna ignore
it likely anyway after you go this is a
waste of time you're capable of doing
more you should not be with this company
I would call that guy like right now and
say hey is that job still open and it's
not yet offered it like this is what I'm
selling he's my he's my mentor ways to
meet great one time I love the word REO
I'd love to work for you
I love you you're like a huge mentor for
me is there any opportunity to work for
you don't quit your job to go to nothing
finding a job that's gonna be better
that hopefully pays you more and when
you're gonna actually learn something
that look talking about money if I go to
this guy
and I and I tell him what I want to do I
the way I would approach it is kind of
work for you but I don't I don't think
it would be like in exchange for money
because the the knowledge that he would
be giving me to me it would be like but
don't you falter thinking that you're
not gonna get paid because I still have
to like pay for for things for school
and great awesome
so get paid yeah he may say no you say
you know what it only works if you work
for three months for free okay then you
can make the decision but don't just
default to say he's not gonna pay you
anything ever
yeah message to the guy if that guy gave
you the same minimum wage that you got
now but you're working for him and he's
mentoring you to help you learn and grow
and help him build his business to would
you make the switch from your current
company in three weeks
and do it
and then apply that thinking and then we
got lot sauce on schedule but like apply
the thinking to everything in your
schedule what am i spending my time on
is this the best use of my time like
it's never that like Danny doing AC
repair could have been like one more
season you know like these guys put a
Danny brahim put put so much into me to
train me in like I owe it to them and
this is such a hot summer season and
like they really need the AC repair but
then if you keep thinking like that you
never get out because it's always gonna
be a little bit more that you could have
done a little bit more you could have
done you're never quite happy with
results is and for an ambitious guy
there's you're never done I want my
YouTube channel to hit 10 million and
then it's gonna be more like you're
never done
do you understand I understand I
understand letting them go no you're not
letting them down that in my home no
you're not no you're not I knows my
office no no no no no no no no you're
not like I started so just as how you
leaves even I I believe I got a handle
it's crazy for my age and then I'm just
like three four more no you're not
dropping just like by you know what no
no
[Music]
don't be an ass don't be an ass you're
not gonna be an ass give them value and
help them for free afterwards if they
need question Q&A whatever but you need
to do what's right for you you've given
them more value than you've received
three weeks notice is way more than most
people and work your face off for those
three weeks which is way more than any
word to give them and then go actually
learn and get paid and then apply that
same strategy to everything else that
you doing you break this thinking like
you fixed that dude with all of your
other natural talent and just like
pleasure to be around this you're gonna
be unstoppable
you're already unstoppable it's just
like you figure it out now at 17 or do
you wait till 27 love you man you got
this
iMessage that guy right now go outside a
messaging if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
that would become like a little beacon
this interview is done as a part of my
Toronto workshop if you want more
details on the next one to sign up check
out the link right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there